this is from the daily wire
uh more disturbing news for you if you
wanted some more the highest ranking
transgender person the by administration
who was also a pediatrician claimed
there is no argument among medical
professionals about the value and the
importance of gender affirming care
is speaking to the national public radio
admiral rachel levine the u.s assistant
secretary for health used the
opportunity to attack florida surging
general joseph ladapo an ally of florida
gop governor ron desantis levine accused
lodapo of putting out a statement based
upon political considerations that is
not appropriate
ladapo had released a fact sheet on
april 20th that stated uh it would
clarify evidence recently cited on a
fact sheet released by the us department
of health human services
and now the
health and human services rachel levine
and he's coming out and saying not just
that it's acceptable to perform chemical
castration on children and to sterilize
children but actually that there's
there's no argument about it whatsoever
and the response i've heard from the
right
to this
is that uh well that's that's absurd
that's ridiculous so of course there's
there's arguments within the medical
community about this
but actually rachel levine in this case
is more right than we would like to
think
not right about it being acceptable or
okay to do that to kids obviously that
is uh that's
child abuse that's worse than child
abuse and everybody involved should go
to prison forever
but
in terms of the the medical communi
community the medical industry
there is now almost
unanimous agreement
because they've pushed all the
dissenting voices out
and whatever descending voices could
still remain within that community have
mostly been silenced or they have
silenced themselves out of fear and
cowardice i mean remember i have to keep
um emphasizing this because i i just
i i feel like we're not we're not
focusing on it quite quite enough it was
the american
academy of pediatrics last week that put
out that book
um
promoting you know a book for kids which
was charting on the children's
bestseller list
below my own book by the way my book was
uh
actually we just found out from amazon
side note that's um
according to amazon charts johnny the
walrus was the number one book in the
entire country last week so that was
good news
and uh this disgusting book for the
american academy pediatrics was below
that but even so
american academy pediatrics that was
their book promoting puberty blockers
chemical castration sterilization for
kids
okay and that's is in terms of the
medical community
that's as mainstream as you can possibly
get
and so when rachel levine claims
when he says that there's no argument
that you know within within the medical
community
it is a it is a shame and an outrage
that that is almost almost true there
are exceptions
but they are few and far between
which does not at all even a little bit
serve to legitimize
this kind of butchery that's done to
children and the drugging of doesn't
certainly delegitimize it what it does
unfortunately is serve to further
de-legitimize the medical industry
they have delegitimized themselves
by putting politics and putting ideology
and uh and also putting their own
professional advancement
above
their oath
to do no harm you know to treat not to
harm they've they've put politics
ideology personal advancement above all
of that far above it
whereas the actual what is supposed to
be the actual purpose of medicine is now
it's not even an afterthought in many of
these cases
and especially when it comes to gender
confused children
it's not an afterthought you know the
idea of like actually helping these kids
and treating whatever ails them
and most of the time what's ailing them
it's a mental thing and it's not even a
mental illness it's just confusion
and understandable confusion given the
environment they're in and so treating
them doesn't require drugs doesn't it
doesn't even require intense therapy in
many of these cases
it's just sitting them down and telling
them the truth and explaining it
[Music]
um but no it's that's not an
afterthought that's just that's not a
thought at all that's not anywhere on
the radar they're not going to do that
for these kids well i hope you enjoyed
that clip for the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content